good morning believe nation today's
message is put yourself in their shoes
over to you Madeleine Albright you often
negotiate with people that you don't
like or you disagree with
I do think no matter whom with whom
you're negotiating you do have to put
yourself into their shoes and try to
figure out what it is they want out of
the meeting as much as what you want out
of the meeting I think you have to
establish a relationship and try to have
just kind of normal conversation but
ultimately you are there for a reason so
you have to state what it is that you
need out of the meeting I used to say I
have come a long way so I must be frank
but I do think that it's that
combination of trying to figure out what
the other person needs and then being
very clear about what you have to
achieve in the meeting I often get asked
by entrepreneurs how do I convince
something to buy from me right how do I
convince that prospect that I'm the best
person to go with and the answer is you
don't try to convince them you use your
ears to listen to them to understand
what their challenges are to put
yourself in their shoes and then see if
you're the best fit for them and I want
to share a quick story I just came back
from Microsoft not too long ago and so
Microsoft is a client of mine now and I
use a lot of Microsoft products I use
the entire office suite you know I can't
live without Word and Excel and
PowerPoint and I use Skype a lot every
day I use Skype and it's my main phone
line it's a lot of office products that
I don't use I use a lot of office
competitors you know I use Evernote
instead of OneNote I use Gmail instead
of Outlook I use Dropbox instead of
onedrive I use a lot of competing
products so when I went to Microsoft to
visit their head office I was really
interested in intrigue to learn hmm
maybe I should be using these other
products as well does it fit my business
or not because I'm not gonna recommend
to you guys to go use a product that I
am not using and getting a lot of value
from and that was one of my main
going there to understand can these
other products help me in my business
and can they potentially help you in
your business because I'd love to share
that so I want to tell the story of
three different salespeople that I met
there the first person took the approach
of I'm going to convince you that
Microsoft is the best I have such
passion for Microsoft and I'm convinced
that we're the best in everything and
I'm gonna convince you by the end of
this conversation with you you're gonna
be convinced that Microsoft is the best
for everything and right away just think
about that attitude right what's your
immediate reaction immediately you're
thinking well that's BS you have your
defense metrics up right now I'm now I'm
worried about what's gonna happen
because I feel like this person doesn't
understand me and I still listen I still
talk to her I was still trying to get
information out but everything she said
I took with a grain of salt because she
made very clear where her intentions
were upfront and now I'm left to figure
out for myself is this gonna be a good
solution for me or not where the next
two guys that I met took an opposite
approach one guy was focused on hardware
Microsoft phones and technology and the
other guys focused on their online tools
and both of them started the
conversation with listen I don't know if
Microsoft is gonna be a fit for you but
I love to learn a little bit more about
your business and learn about the
problems that you're facing and see if
we might be able to help right away I'm
feeling a lot more safe and secure I'm
feeling that my guards are let down more
and that's what I wanted I want an open
conversation be able to explain what I'm
going through what I'm using now and can
you help me can you be the solution for
me and so I think too many entrepreneurs
take that first approach the approach of
that first that first lady were like I
am so convinced that you need to buy my
product without ever even listening to
your customers to understand what their
needs are and if you can be like the
other two guys the people who are using
their ears who are trying to understand
your challenges who might be willing to
say listen I don't think Microsoft is a
fit for you this time around the next
time I have a problem the next time I
have a question about a Microsoft
product something that I think hey maybe
this will fit for my business who do you
think I'm gonna go back to the answer is
obvious it's gonna be one of the two
guys who I feel like actually listened
and cared about my business not the one
who's just trying to sell me
stuff so anytime you want somebody to
take an action whether it's your
business partner whether it's a customer
whether it's an investor whether it's
the media try first to put yourself in
their shoes have some empathy have some
understanding because the more you can
do that the more you can understand what
they're after the better you can
position your product your company your
service and the better you can help them
get the objective they're after so the
question of the day today is I'd love to
know when the last time you put yourself
in somebody else's shoes was tell me the
story leave in the comments below I'm
really curious to find out thank you so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso